Okay.
What time is it?
Eight 50 I started when [inaudible] sorry.
It's been
six 30.
I should stop them.
[inaudible]
I'm going to go for five more minutes and then I'll wrap this up.
I want to talk about intersectionality and and white privilege a bit.
Yeah.
So,
so I first said,
well,
we analyzed Marxism.
We out,
I analyze postmodernism.
Okay.
I suggested that postmodernism was a way for the Marxists to keep going under a
new guys.
I suggested that Marxism was fundamentally based on hatred rather than sympathy
and empathy.
I suggested that the carbs is where the,
the evidence for that.
Um,
I told you why I think postmodernism is fundamentally wrong.
MMM.
Now I want to talk to you a little bit about white privilege.
Yeah.
So the first thing that I can,
and I haven't got this quite figured out yet,
I can't quite figure out why the postmodernists have made the canonical
distinctions.
They made race,
ethnicity,
sexual proclivity,
sexual gender identity.
Let's say those are four dimensions along which people vary.
But there's a very large number of dimensions along which people vary,
right?
In fact,
given that there's an infinite number of ways of interpreting the world,
you can immediately point out if there's an infinite number of dimensions along
which people vary.
And so then the postmodern question is why would you privilege some of those
dimensions over the other?
And I would say,
well,
because it sustains your bloody Marxist interpretation.
That's why.
But you're not going to say that cause it marginalizes,
right?
You've marginalized that so you can ignore it.
So that's one of the fun things about postmodernism.
You can,
you can.
I have a very vulgar image in my mind,
but
I won't share that with you,
but you can infer it.
Here's some ways people differ.
Intelligence,
temperament,
geography,
historical time.
You live now and not a hundred years ago.
Attractiveness.
That's a big,
that's a big one.
That's a big one.
Would you imagine?
You,
you could.
You won't.
We won't go there either.
You eat it's advantages to be young.
You've got potential disadvantageous to be old.
You've got wealth,
health,
that's a good one.
Sex women have advantages.
Men advantages.
Maybe one has more than the other.
It's not self evident.
Women live about eight years longer.
They're multiorgasmic,
athleticism,
wealth,
family structure,
friendship,
education.
Well then there's the classic,
you know,
postmodern once,
race,
ethnicity,
et cetera.
Why not those other dimensions of variation,
there's no evidence that they're less important.
In fact,
there's quite a bit of evidence that they're more important,
so like why not consider them?
Then you get intersectionality.
This is one of the things that's really comical,
I think because the postmodernists identity politics types actually realized
this.
They thought,
well,
okay,
race and gender.
Fair enough.
What if you're,
what if you're a black woman?
But that's a problem because well now you've got two dimensions of
differentiation.
What the hell are we going to do about that?
And what if you're,
what if you're gay and black and female?
Well,
then what if you're not very bright and gay and black and female,
and then what if you're ugly and not very bright and gay and black and female
and like you can keep playing that game.
You can keep playing that game and infinite number of ways because there's an
infinite number of ways to categorize things.
As the postmodern authority pointed out.
And so the intersectionality theorist came along to plug the hole,
but they don't know where they're going.
They don't understand that the logical conclusion of intersectionality is
individuality because there's so many different ways of categorizing people's
advantages and disadvantages that if you take that all the way out to the end,
you say,
well the individuals,
the ultimate minority.
And that's exactly right.
And that's exactly what the West discovered.
And you know the intersection lists of get there if they don't kill everyone
first.
So on to white privilege.
So it's really interesting to find out where these ideas come from cause it's
usually the scholarship is so awful,
you just cannot possibly believe it.
It's just absolutely,
it wouldn't.
At the University of Toronto in the psychology department,
the original paper on white privilege wouldn't have received a passing grade for
the hypothesis part of a undergraduate honors thesis.
We're not even close.
There's no methodology at all.
The person who wrote it,
it was called white privilege and male privilege.
A personal account of coming to see correspondences through work in women's
studies.
Well,
first of all,
personal account.
It's like,
sorry.
No,
so she,
she listed a bunch of ways that she thought.
She says these are personal personal examples of her unearned privilege or
unearned privilege that she saw as she experienced in the 1970s 1980s so this,
by the way,
that,
so this idea is the opinion of one person who wrote one paper that has
absolutely no empirical backing,
which is a set of hypotheses which had never been subject to any statistical
analysis.
Like if I ask you a bunch of questions,
it's not obvious how many questions I'm asking you because I could say,
how tall are you?
Or I could say,
if you're laying on the ground,
how extended would you be?
It's like that.
Two questions.
It's like,
no,
it's one question.
It's just as two ways and the way you figure out if you ask someone a bunch of
questions,
how many questions you're asking them is by doing something called a factor
analysis,
which is kind of an an elementary form.
Okay.
Now of social science investigation.
If you make a questionnaire you have to subject it to a factor analysis cause
you got to find out how many questions you're asking because you might think
it's 60 but it's probably not.
It's probably five.
That's the big five by the way.
Anyways,
who cares about that?
There's no such thing as methodology.
Anyways,
that's all part of the oppressive white male European patriarchy,
so we can just not bother with that and we can pen a few notes about how we
think the world is constructed and then we can screw up the entire political
system two decades later.
Okay,
so here's your white privilege lists.
Some of it,
there's like 50 things I can,
if I wish arrange to be in the company of people of my race most of the time if
I should need to move,
I can be pretty sure of renting or purchasing housing in an area which I can
afford and in which I would want to live.
That's actually a wealth thing by the way.
I can be pretty sure that my neighbors in such a location will be neutral or
pleasant to me.
I can go shopping alone most of the time,
pretty well assured that I will not be followed or harassed.
I can turn on my television or open to the front page of the paper and see
people of my waist race widely represented.
Okay.
When I am told about our national heritage or about civilization,
I am shown that people of my color made it what it is.
Okay.
Oh,
there's 50 of those I think.
Something like that.
Okay.
Is that white privilege?
Is that like majority privilege?
Okay.
It's the same tree.
You go to China,
you're Chinese.
It's the same.
True.
If you're Chinese
does the majority privilege and if it's majority privileges,
like isn't that just part of living within your culture?
So let's say you live in your culture.
You're privileged as a member of that culture.
Well,
obviously that's what the culture is for.
That's what it's for.
Why would you bother building the damn thing if it didn't accrue benefits to
you?
Now you might say,
well,
one of the consequences that it accrues fewer benefits to those who aren't in
the culture.
Yeah,
but you can't immediately associate that with race.
You can't just do that.
Say It's white privileged.
There's many things it could be certainly could be wealth and the intersection
people have already figured out that there's many things that could be.
Yeah,
so like what the hell?
Seriously.
Well,
what's going on while we left these pseudo disciplines into the university
because we're stupid and guilty.
Seriously,
and they have no methodological requirements and plenty of power and plenty of
time to produce nonsensical research and produce like resentful activists and
now we're bearing the fruits of that.
It's not pretty so white privilege.
Well,
the other thing you might notice is that to attribute to the individuals of a
community,
the attributes of that community on the basis of their racial identity is called
racism.
That's what racism is.
There's no other way of defining it.
It's attributing to the individual the characteristics of the group as if the
group was homogenous.
Now the intersectional people have already decided that's not a fair game
because there's so many differences between people.
But the postmodernists don't care about logical coherence because they regard
logical coherence.
Here it comes again as a creation of the white,
European male patriarchal structure that's designed to oppress the oppressed.
And that's technically the case.
So logical incoherence,
it doesn't matter.
And you could say,
well,
if you act out your logically incoherent ideas in the world,
you're going to run face first into a brick wall.
And the postmodern answer to that is there's actually no real world.
It's all interpretation.
So there's no,
there's no having that discussion,
but the postmodernists don't care because they don't believe that discussion
between people of different power groups as possible.
Anyways.